bienvenue dans mon bureau
quand tu es prêt touche cette boule et
l'une des trois lumières va s'allumer
Adrien
ce matin lors de l'audiant à huis clos 4
mois de prison avec sursis voilà la
peine prononcer contre lui pour avoir
donné une gifle à son épouse à peine
arrivé on a remarqué plusieurs codages
effectués pendant la nuit sur le
bâtiment
un agresseur ne peut être député ou
encore Céline on te croit sauf qu'en
refaisant un petit tour des lieux on est
tombé sur des soutiens du député en
train de les décoller
[Musique]
elle m'a regardé
je l'ai regardé elle m'a regardé
j'ai attendu
bref c'est très long tout ça
de féministe et on peut savoir qui vous
êtes
des proches
son Commentaire
face à des militants insoumis venus le
soutenir pas d'animosité entre mais la
discussion et franche comment un homme
agresseur peut porter la lutte contre
les violences
les d'abord sont tempérament
la recherche la recherche de conquêtes
rapidement négocier et régler et d'autre
part aussi le comportement peut-être de
certaines jeunes femmes comme pour les
chanteurs etc qui viennent les chercher
donc mais lui a probablement
exagéré et considérablement exagéré
voilà et en fait c'est ce contrat de cul
là les femmes font ah oui merci merci
encore encore voilà je vous laisse
essayer ça vous voir
et c'est parti il faut que ça donne la
même sensation donc Marjorie n'hésitez
pas à lui dire plus haut plus machin
plus trop
vous comprenez qu'on puisse être un
petit peu choqué parce que vous voulez
dire sur le fait que c'était la faute
des victimes
quelle ambiance quelle ambiance de merde
c'est tout le temps comme ça
toujours sous d'habitude collé à la main
la photo de cette activité colo est très
relayée sur les réseaux sociaux ou
certains doutes de son authenticité
c'est pourtant vrai l'homme a utilisé un
mélange de sable et de gluc pour se
coller à la chaussée lors d'une action
en Allemagne la police a dû faire appel
à des ouvriers de construction routière
pour le décoller les ouvriers ont donc
dû utiliser une scie circulaire pour
couper le bitume qui se trouvait autour
de la main de l'activiste en revanche il
ne s'agit pas d'un certain Dimitri
Rousseau ne veut de Sandrine Rousseau la
députée écologiste française comme de
très nombreux internautes ont tenté de
le faire croire Raoul zemmler c'est son
nom est un comédien et activiste
allemand pour ceux qui s'inquiéteraient
il n'a pas perdu sa main
parfois il faut braver le danger pour
être un héros formidable
c'est pourri par terre c'est juste pas
possible ça colle c'est grave c'est
affreux affreux affreux un fourneau dans
cet état-là un seul couvert en une
matinée là on a un service là tu as
pourri le truc comme ça tu vois quand je
vois ça j'ai envie de dégueuler et vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure la caricature
des des Guignols est-ce que je peux dire
en riant toujours
avec un certain sérieux quel était
particulièrement une caricature
antisémite si vous voyez l'image
carrément carrément je le dis je la fais
parler de votre marionnette ma
marionnette son fourreau protège son
porteur de toutes blessure le roi Arthur
détenant les deux étaient donc
invincible sur les champs de bataille
l'épée
il a l'argent les patates regardez il a
tout pour la caricature c'est ça
ressemble au caricature qui avait dans
les années entre 30 et 40 en France vous
voyez là vous allez un peu fort parce
que c'est les Guignols n'étaient pas
spécialement comme ça bon pour beaucoup
d'entre vous ça n'a pas vraiment
d'importance
j'ai dépensé pas loin de 10000 dollars
je déteste penser à ce chiffre mais
partager l'esprit de Noël n'a pas de
prix
comment vivre à Santa Claus la ville du
Père Noël aux États-Unis il ne pas
répondre à ce devoir sacré des lumières
de Noël
tu fais des soirées là tu es là regarde
on va se faire une petite brochette on
se fait un petit barbec on est pas bien
là regarde au milieu du bourbier
c'est pas sympathique
on passe un petit moment tranquille là
dans un espace privilégié
[Musique]
on se croirait presque au bord de la mer
c'est le chef des Français j'ai pas voté
pour lui je n'aime pas Macron je n'aime
pas son gouvernement je n'aime pas je
vais pas vous dire tout ce que j'aime
pas chez eux parce que ça va ça peut
durer longtemps et d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
bravo à Monsieur Djebari parce que
j'aime l'entendre alors que je le
détestais quand il était ministre
rédemption j'adore cette conversation
de politique on peut enfin parler avec
alors un terme qui est un peu galvaudé
ce qu'on appelle le bon sens
écoutez-le sur la pénibilité vous allez
comprendre pourquoi je dis ça
aujourd'hui la nature du travail n'est
pas la même les déménageurs les
couvrants les gens dans les travaux
publics sont équipés de d'exosquelettes
ils sont équipés de matériaux mais là
Monsieur Djibril est très bien il est
très très bien bravo
à l'époque où il était il était ministre
j'étais pas content
parce que je suis plutôt dans votre cas
au départ c'était le seul ministre avec
Monsieur de Normandie c'était deux seuls
avec qui on pouvait discuter et qui
avait qui avait aussi du bon sens même
interminé je l'avais dit ici
vous êtes déjà venu dans l'émission tout
à fait c'était il y a combien de temps
c'était il y a un peu plus d'un an on
avait parlé de votre ressemblance à
Rocco Siffredi et ça n'a pas arrangé
votre vie quotidienne et bien en effet
il arrive qu'on arrête dans la rue et
qu'on me dise ah c'est vous Rocco
Siffredi c'est joli c'est bien je suis
désolé demande des autographes parfois
il y a l'empreinte carbone N'oubliez pas
les paroles
je vous explique où je suis je suis dans
la salleuse en train de parcourir les
les rues de Roanne avec Jacky qui est
d'astreinte à Roanne en ce moment pour
la neige et puis au volant on a on a
Michel et bien merci Jacquie et Michel
l'info reviens demain